Шановні батьки шановні випускники
2023 року ми сьогодні проводимо разом з
комітетом освіти науки та інновації
проводимо
перший бріфінг стосовно запропонованої
узгодженої нами всіма моделі вступу і в
цьому контексті Я хочу сказати що
перші підсумки які відбулися під час
2022 року під час війни
дозволили нам констатувати що
той механізм та модель вступу яка була
запропонована міністерством разом з
комітетом на 2022 рік виявилось успішною
і ми маємо
велику рекорну кількість
зарахованих до
професійно-технічної до фахових
перевищень до вищих закладів освіти в
2022 році а саме це 602 майже 622 тисячі
вступників
окремим інструментом або окремим
елементом моделі цього вступу був вступ
в закладах
і установах
інших країн можливості забезпечення
вступу наших абітурієнтів випускників 11
класів в 58 містах і 32-х країнах світу
і на сьогодні враховуючи безпеку
ситуацію враховуючи
побажання батьків вчителів ми всі і я і
голова комітету голова профільного під
комітету
систематично впродовж року відвідували
області відвідували школи відвідували
університети і набирали статистику щодо
прийняття рішень по формуванню моделів
вступу на 2023 рік
ще раз нагадаю що сьогодні єдиним
інструментом є зовнішнє незалежне
оцінювання але враховуючи безпеку у
ситуацію ми моделюємо
максимально безпековий вступ враховуємо
думку батьків і вступників і подає на
розгляд Верховної Ради спільно узгоджено
модель вступу в рамках
вдосконаленого національно
мультиплідненого тесту по вступу 2023
року який буде складатись з двох
обов'язкових предметів і одного з
предметів на вибір буде триватись 180
хвилин інші деталі будуть Мої колеги теж
розкриють Дякую вам Я запрошую до слова
голову комітету освіти науки та
інновації в селі вітальчева пока Доброго
дня шановні колеги Доброго дня Україна
насправді в нас точилися дискусії
по кількості обов'язкових предметів чи
будемо давати предмети на вибір один
день складати чи в два дні складати всі
пам'ятають ці дискусії насправді для нас
два основні чинники власне фактори на
яких ми базувалися це перша що сказав
Сергій Миколайович це питання безпеки
друге - це питання того що ми хочемо щоб
абітурієнти проявили свої найкращі
здібності тому буде два обов'язкових
предмета українська мова і математика Ну
і третій предмет на вибір для того щоб
ті хто вступають на медицину проявили
себе з біології ті хто вступають на
природничі спеціальності проявили себе з
фізики хімії
ті хто на гуманітарні звісно за історію
України іноземної мови довжину тесту
справді 180 хвилин і в межах цих 180
хвилин буде три блоки запитань з трьох
предметів але ці 180 хвилин в принципі
на всі блоки розраховані тобто одному
можна приділити більш часу іншим у менше
часу я сподіваюся що вступна кампанія
пройде спокійно є вже часові рамки коли
вона буде проходити все зрозуміло
Український Центр Оцінювання Якості
готовий Міністерство готове комітет
готовий в нас буде засідання комітету
через дві години де ми Приймемо
відповідний проект закону ухвалимо я
головнокомітеті і на найближчому
засіданні Верховної Ради ми його
обов'язково Приймемо тому я всім бажаю
вступникам гарної вступної кампанії
віримо в збройні сили і боремося за
Україну Дякую дякую Сергій Віталійович
шановні шановні українці Шановні батьки
Шановні вступники я хочу передати слово
голові під комітету з вищої освіти саме
На цьому під комітеті під керівництвом
Юлії Микола вони Грішина відбувалися так
скажімо тестові
тестування цієї запропонованої моделі в
різних варіантах і саме на підкомітеті
було прийнято базове рішення яке потім
озвучувалось на комітеті з декількох
запропонованих і е-е
згоду по якому ми сьогодні саме
представляємо І через деякий час воно
буде представлено комітеті людина
запрошує вас
Дякую Сергій Миколайович шановні наші
школярі майбутньої абітурієнти батьки
колеги ми дійсно попрацювали командою і
сьогодні представляємо модель вступної
кампанії 20-23 яка по аналогії з минулим
роком буде проводитися вже в
умовах війни і ми залишаємо два основні
принципи
на яких ми будуємо фактично нашу вступну
компанію перший принцип - це безпека
всіх учасників і другий принцип - це
загальне збереження принципів
зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання в тих
умовах війни в яких його можна зберегти
в нас є досвід Минулого року коли наші
абітурієнти складали 3 іспити в один
день ми це вже прийшли ця модель у нас
відпрацьована Ми залишаємо цю модель і
на цей рік дійсно буде 3 іспити які
будуть складатися в один день і
відрізнятись буде ситуація в цьому році
тим що третій іспит можна буде здавати
обирати на вибір абітурієнта в минулому
році в нас була така ситуація що
потрібно було швидко приймати рішення і
не фактично не було об'єктивних
можливостей забезпечити таку
варіативність Зараз ми заздалегідь
готувалися до цієї ситуації ця
можливість є тому третій іспит наші
абітурієнти зможуть обирати той який їм
потрібен безпосередньо профільний для
вступу на певну спеціальність і обрати
Той предмет якому вони приділяли більш
більш більш глибоко його вивчали
І дійсно на під комітеті ми розглядали
різні варіанти зараз зупинилися саме На
цьому це наше спільне рішення і на
комітеті сьогодні через дві години як
сказав буде прийнято рішення щодо того
законопроекту який
найближчими тижнями Скажімо так буде
винесено для голосування зал Дякую
Хочу зазначити що додатково зазначити що
реєстрація на вступ за моделлю
національного мультиплекторного тесту
2023 році буде стартувати у квітні
місяці і при цьому саме третій предмет
який є на вибір буде зазначатися при
реєстрації на відповідному програмному
забезпеченні і на сайті українського
центру оцінювання якості освіти якраз
таки в квітні місяці
в цьому контексті додатково мушу
зазначити що
ми в цілому абсолютно
узгодили позицію що всі пільгові
категорії учасники з тимчасового
окупованих з Део окупованих територій
будуть вступати за будуть мати
можливість вступати за дистанційною
моделлю за їх вибором і після
на впродовж трьох місяців Вони мають
укласти договір вже про приїхавши в
заклад освіти і приступивши до навчання
окрема категорія як і в минулому році
буде стосуватися закладів військової
освіти в закладів спеціальної умовами
навчання які будуть вступати по власних
правилах прийому це ми теж зберігаємо на
на
2023 рік зараз хочу передати слово
Валерію Бойко який
відзначить саме технічні особливості
вступу моделі прийому на 2023 рік але
запрошував Дякую Сергі шановні учасники
шановні освітяни
український центр вже на сьогодні
готовий надати технічні характеристики
тих предметних тестів які будуть
використані на вступні під час наступної
кампанії в 23-му році я вже зазначали
попередній спікери довжина тесту на
виконання якого буде відведено 180
хвилин в цілому буде стандартизованою
варто виокремити практично декілька
блоків предметів де довжина тестів тобто
кількість тестових балів буде однакова
це українська мова це історія України
біологія та хімія 30 завдань на 100
умовно ми говоримо зі 180 хвилин дитина
може витратити в цілому орієнтуючись що
на такими блоками Вона може працювати
близько години 60 хвилин другий блок
найбільш Скажімо так трудомістки які
вимагатиме від дітей працювання завдань
не тільки закритої форми з вибором
відповідей але і надання короткої
відповіді обчислення розрахункових задач
це тести з математики і фізики кількість
таких завдань які буде включено
відповідно 22 і 20 ну і відповідно
окремо можемо говорити про
тест з іноземних мов які будуть
представлені завданнями з англійської
німецької французької та іспанської мови
він включатиме 32 завдання завдання
виключно будуть стосуватися
розуміння вірніше будуть стосуватися
виключно читання та перевірки
лексико-граматичних мін та навичок
випускників традиційні для зовнішнього
незалежного оцінювання такі частини як
розуміння мови на слух перевірка іншими
словами кажучи аудіювання та перевірка
писемного мовлення абітурієнтів
здійснюватися не буде так само як і в
українській мові
звичної для моделі ЗНО
писемного мовлення у вигляді власного
висловлення на запропоновану тему також
не буде на сьогоднішній день український
центр за допомогою та їх тих
комп'ютерних засобів на якій
реалізується вступна кампанія 22-го року
не готовий ще реалізувати і
запропонувати учасникам е-е роботу з
відкритими завданнями і відповідно з
організацією процесу перевірки таких
завдань але з огляду на те що
український центр використовує закриті
завдання вони є максимально технологічні
внутрішні калькулятор самої платформи
дозволятиме дитині отримувати результат
одразу після того як вона виконає всі
завдання того чи іншого блоку виходять
чи з аудиторії вона буде знати свій
результат в тестових балах
новацією в порівнянні з попереднім роком
щодо структури тесту полягає в тому що в
минулому році левова частка завдань які
включалися до тестів з математики
історії та української
були завдання з вибором однієї
правильної відповіді та завдання на
встановлення відповідності цього року
платформа буде доопрацьована І ми
суттєво розширимо наші можливості з
використання інших форматів завдання які
були притаманні саме системі ЗНО і в цій
ситуації Варто сказати Наприклад що в
історії України буде представлена такий
формат завдань як встановлення
хронологічної послідовності Це доволі
таки важливий специфічний формат для
такого предмета як історія тому що
хронологічна компетентність компетенція
перевіряється виключно на цьому предметі
крім того буде запропоновано низка
завдань на вибір декількох правильних
відповідей із
запропонованого набору відповідей Тобто
ми максимально намагатимемося
використати потенціал того чи іншого
формату завдань для того щоб охопити
максимально ті знання вміння і навички
які наче абітурієнти здобувають або
завершують здобувати на етапі завершення
повної загальної середньої освіти варто
зазначити також що в контексті
запропонованих
форматів завдань наперед чітко буде
українським центром розроблено
демонстраційний варіант тесту ми його
щонайменше не пізніше квітня оприлюднимо
в двох форматах це буде звичайний
заверстаний pdf-файл для того щоб дитина
могла ознайомитися з усією лінійкою
предметів які включено до переліку
вступних іспитів Ну і також буде
запропоновано онлайн-тестувальник де
дитина також може потренуватися
працювати саме в комп'ютерному форматі
інша особливість цього року в порівнянні
з минулого
запроваджується так званий мінімальний
прохідний бал який буде дорівнювати не
менше 10% для кожного навчального
предмету в залежності від тієї
максимальної кількості балів яку буде
запропоновано
в тому чи іншому варіанті тестів
передбачається що відповідні таблиці
переведення тестових балів як і в
минулому році будуть затверджені в
своєчасно в міністерством освіти і науки
а український центр зробить усе можливе
для того щоб результати в тестових балах
абітурієнта своєчасно відображалися на
інформаційних сторінках і за шкалою 100
200 також що варто знати про результати
це те що
поняття вагові коефіцієнти цього року
також будуть застосовані до того чи
іншого предмету який обере дитина Ну і
ще що важливо сказати це те що
тестування буде проходити в тимчасових
екзаменаційних центрах Ми плануємо їх
створювати як в межах нашої держави
України так і
з опертя на досвід Минулого року будемо
проводити тестування в деяких країнах за
кордоном сподіваюсь що нам вдасться
реалізувати ідею міністра що такими
осередками створення
використовують екзаменаційних центрів
будуть освітні хаби створені за межами
нашої держави Ну і насамкінець варто
наголосити що особливістю підготовки для
наших абітурієнтів особливі підготовки
має полягати в тому що це сумлінне
опанування навчальним матеріалом з
опертям на програми ЗНО вони є чинними
все те що викладено в програмі ЗНО все
це і буде перевірятися під час вступної
кампанії для підготовки радо радив би
також використовувати всі ресурси
українського центру тести минулих років
завдання які оприлюднено за всі
попередні роки і ЗНО і нмт ви зможете
якомога сумлінніше їх опрацювавши
найкраще підготуватися до вступної
кампанії продемонструвати свій найкращий
результат в мене все дякую дякую Євгене
шановні
абітурієнти шановні випускники Ще раз
Хочу наголосити використовувати лише
офіційну інформацію щодо матеріалів
підготовки оскільки минулий рік ми
стикали з тим що було дуже багато
інформації які готували приватні
репетитори я ніяким чином не заперечую
стосовно підготовки будким але
використовуйте для підготовки бажано
використовувати виключно інформацію яка
є офіційною оприлюднена на українській
на сайті українського центру оцінювання
якості освіти оскільки там найновіший
матеріали в найсвіжішому форматі
запрошую до слова Олега Юрійовича шарова
Дякую а шановне панство Дозвольте
насамперед а сказати що сьогодні в
законопроекті який буде розглянути
комітетом з освіти науки та інновації
Верховної Ради України передбачається
скасування державної підсумкової
атестації за курс повної загальної
середньої освіти які складають учні 11-х
класів закладів професійної
професійно-технічної освіти і студенти
закладів фахової передвищує освіти тобто
складання національного мультику
предметного тесту будуть його складати
вступники це буде добровільно і не буде
Обов'язковим елементом державної
підсумкової атестації
на ту дискусію яка часто сьогодні
зустрічається в меді хотілося б особливо
підкреслити що національний
мультипредметний тест розглядається як
особливий формат Як адаптація
зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання В
умовах воєнного стану і не варто
протиставляти національний
мультипредметний тест і зовнішнє
незалежне оцінювання дуже важливо що
незалеж від обраного вступником
додаткового предмету позитивний
результат національного мультику
предметного тесту дозволить подавати
заяву для вступу на будь яку
спеціальність підкреслюю будь-які
вибірковий предмет дозволяє подавати
заяву на будь яку спеціальність Звичайно
це буде здійснюватись розраховуватись
конкурсний бал з урахуванням вигових
коефіцієнтів встановлених для предметів
на різні спеціальності
в проекті порядку прийому до закладів
вищої освіти на 2023 рік передбачено що
вступники не містечки та спортивні
спеціальності складатимуть національний
мультипредметний тест та відповідний
творчий конкурс а замість результатів
національного мультику предметного тесту
2023 року можна буде скористатися
результатами національного мультику
предметного тесту 2022 року або
зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання 2021
чи 2020 року у повній відповідності
Законом України Про вищу освіту
вступники до магістратури на основі
ступеня бакалавра вступатимуть за
результатами єдиного вступного іспиту
який поєднує тест загальною навчальною
компетентності відпрацьований в минулому
році та тест з іноземної мови Де також
можна буде обирати англійську німецьку
французьку або іспанську мову на вибір
вступника це буде стосуватися всіх
спеціальностей а єдиний фаховий ступне
Випробування передбачається для
вступників на спеціальність галузі знань
0,5 соціальні та поведінкові науки 0,6
журналістика 07 управління та
адміністрування 0:8 права 28 публічне
управління та адміністрування 29
міжнародні відносини вступники до
магістратури з інших спеціальностей
будуть складати фаховий іспит в закладах
освіти
хотілось би окрема зазначити що без
зовнішніх іспитів без єдиного вступного
іспиту єдиного фахового вступного
випробування І лише за результатами
вступних випробувань у закладі вищої
освіти можна буде вступити на контракт
на навчання на спеціальності і яким
надається особлива підтримка Хочу
зазначити що це 50-3 спеціальності то 11
спеціалізації тому насправді кажучи
Вибір дуже і дуже суттєвий
А вступники які раніше здобули
дипломагістра або диплом спеціаліста
зможуть знову здобувати магістерський
рівень за результатами вступних
випробувань у закладі вищої освіти або
скласти іспити на загальних умовах за їх
вибором крім вступників за спеціальністю
0,81 вправа і 293 міжнародне право які
будуть вступати за загальними правилами
дуже важливий про це Багато запитують що
вступні кампанії 23-го року не
планується використовувати середні бали
раніше здобуток документів про освіту та
сільські коефіцієнт це обумовлена
абсолютно об'єктивними обставинами
можливостями завершення в 2023 році як в
закладах загальної середньої освіти так
і в закладах фахових перевищує вищі
освіти На жаль об'єктивної картини
середні бали і сільський коефіцієнт в
цьому році надавати не буду тому їх
використовувати буде неможливо галузевий
коефіцієнт буде використаний для
підтримки вступників обласної повної
загальної середньої освіти а також
фахову молодшого бакалавра молодшого
спеціаліста молодшого бакалавра з
пріоритетним вибором першої і другої
пріоритетності за однієї спеціальності
які ми надається особлива підтримка і
тільки на спеціальність з особливою
підтримкою регіональний коефіцієнт буде
визначено навесні залежне від розвитку
воєнно-політичної ситуації в Україні А
загалом вступники зможуть подавати до 20
заяв у сукупності за всіма джерелами
фінансування та основами вступу з яких
не більше п'яти заяв на місця державного
та або регіонального замовлення
а в проекті порядку прийому передбачено
що конкурсний бал для вступу за всіма
джерелами фінансування на основі повної
загальної середньої освіти та
освітньо-професійного ступені фахового
молодшого бакалару
освітньо-кваліфікаційного рівня
молодшого спеціаліста ступеня молодшого
бакалавра не може бути меншим ніж 150
балів для лікарських спеціальностей з
яких проводиться підготовка магістрів на
основі повної загальної середньої освіти
та не може бути менше ніж 140 балів для
спеціальності галузі знань право
публічне управління та адміністрування
міжнародні відносини спеціальності
фармації промислово форматі на всі інші
спеціальності вступників будуть
допускатися до конкурсного відбору на
місця державного та регіонального
замовлення і можуть бути рекомендовані
або переведені на такі місця в разі
наявності конкурсного балу не менше 1000
як і в 2022 році для
дітей загиблих захисників і захисниць
України ці вимоги застосовуватись не
будуть нарешті хотів би зазначити що
надання вступникам рекомендації для
навчання в закладах вищої освіти
державної форми власності усіх сфер
управління крім вищих військових
навчальних закладів закладів вищої
освіти і специфічними умовами навчання і
військових навчальних підрозділів
закладів вищої освіти та в закладах
вищої освіти приватної форми власності
Де здійснюється набір за державним
замовленням в закладах комунальної форми
власності за регіональним замовленням
буде проводитись з результатами
адресного розміщення бюджетних місць і
всі ці Результати будуть оприлюднюватись
відео тобто фактично вступник буде
отримувати бюджетне місце від держави
без будь-яких посередників за
результатами свого успішного складання
вступних випробувань зокрема
національного мультику предметного тесту
планується також розширення використання
широкого конкурсу наступ до магістратури
за спеціальностями де передбачено
складання єдиного фахового вступного
Випробування а суттєво зменшується
регулювання розподілу бюджетних міст з
державними замовниками на користь
прозорих і повністю автоматизованих
процедур Міністерство освіти і науки не
планує встановлювати фіксований поділ
бюджетних місць
між вступниками на основі повної
загальної середньої освіти вступниками
на основі молодшого спеціаліста чи
фахового молодшого вокалавра тобто ті
категорії вступників братимуть участь у
спільних широких конкурсах з
використанням однакового розрахунку
конкурсного балу Що дозволить
розподілити бюджетні місця на користь
краще підготовлених вступників дякую
Шановні колеги ми завершили
презентаційну частину брифінгу
Запрошуємо до шановних журналістів до
запитань Дякуємо нашим спікерам так-так
бачу в нас журналісти присутні в залі а
також представники ЗМІ мали змогу
залишити свої питання за формою тож
розпочнемо спочатку з питань які
залишили попередній перейдемо до ваших
питань Отож питання таке за якими
стандартами та методологією розроблялося
нмте з англійської мови та за якими
критеріями будуть оцінюватися нмтези
іноземних мов і за якими критеріями
будуть обиратися фахівці для перевірки
думаю що це питання до феверей Іванович
будь ласка Валерій Іванович прошу вас
Я вже в цілому сказав що тести з
іноземних мов не включатимуть дві
важливі складові які ми зазвичай
перевіряли під час проведення
зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання це
перевірка розуміння мови на слух
аудіювання і перевірка писемного
мовлення ці частини відсутні а отже для
перевірки писем замовлення не потрібно
буде залучати екзаменаторів тобто ані з
приватних закладів ані з комунальних
державних закладів освіти залучатися
люди цього року в такій категорії як
екзаменатори не будуть що стосується
стандартів розроблення то український
центр
розробляючи інструменти оцінювання в
першу чергу з іноземної мови з іноземною
мовою послуговується
загальноєвропейськими рекомендаціями ми
фактично оперуємо
тими поняттями які
застосовуються в загальних рекомендаціях
Ради Європи з питань вивчення іноземних
мов і маю сказати що ми і послуговуємося
класичними
форматами завдань як правило
перевіряється загальне розуміння мови
тексту повне розуміння розуміння
структури тексту вибіркове розуміння Ну
і відповідно перевірка
лексико-граматичних умінь Тобто це ми
можемо вважати стандартами які також
викладені в програмі ЗНО з іноземних мов
Валерій Іваничі ще одне питання яка буде
програма нмт з історії
Я хотів би підкреслити що незалежно від
того який предмет дитина обере для
проходження національного та предметного
тесту в ньому будуть включені завдання
зміст яких 100%
відповідатимейні зовнішнього незалежного
оцінювання з того чи іншого навчального
предмету досвід Минулого року проведення
підкреслю обов'язкового предмету з
історії України
дозволив нам провести ммт з історії
України виключно з опиттям на навчальний
матеріал Які діти опановують в 10-11
класі Тобто це історія України XX
століття
нмт-23-го року змістово буде охоплювати
теми які викладені в теми які викладені
в програмі ЗНО починаючи від другої
половини 16 століття до початку 21
століття якщо говорити в межах як це
вивчається в школі то це навчальний
матеріал 8-9-10 та 11-го класу давньої
давньоруської історії і середньовічної
історії
в тестах з історії України представлено
не буде Дякую за відповідь будь ласка
представників ЗМІ було тут питання прошу
представитись і задати ваше питання
день і на Боднар ТСН 1+1 пане міністр до
вас найперше уточнення ви сказали що з
окупованих територій дистанційно зможуть
нам те пройти уточніть будь ласка
як і в 22-му році так і в 23-му ми
ставимо перш за все завдання в
збереження
можливості будь-якого українця незалежно
від місця проживання
мати можливість вступу до закладів вищої
освіти саме України саме тому і діти з
окупованих тимчасово окупованих
територій будуть мати можливість за їх
вибором вступати дистанційно
які закордон торік ми мали великий
перелік країн в цьому році на такі ж
самі країни Ми розраховуємося але ці 32
країни там вже сформовані вже сформовані
центри тестування МТ які відбувалися в
минулому році але на цьому Ми ще
розраховуємо додатково на тій 17
освітній хабіб які вже існують тільки
Україна створила завдячуючи нашим
партнерам в інших країнах світу і плюс
будемо вести перемовини з іншими
країнами для створення таких самих
центрів тестування Дякую
Минулого року було дві сесії ранкова і
обідня цього зміни дві зміни Так в цьому
році так само буде тоді були закиди що
повторювалися тести і типу хто складав
пізніше було виграші Дякую Ну по-перше
все те що стосується повторення завдань
і
суджень що Хтось мав якусь перевагу в
порівнянні з іншим тому що стали йому
відомі
завдання які були використані під час
попередніх змін нашої внутрішнє
дослідження показало що це абсолютно не
відповідає дійсності і ми відповідної
інформації оприлюднювали в себе на сайті
те що стосується Ну треба розуміти в яку
В якій стислі терміни готувалися в
минулому році тести для потреби
проведення
нмт Минулого року Нам необхідно було з
самого початку ми розуміли потужності
платформи щонайменше 16 варіантів але по
факту виявилося що кількість змін які ми
можемо провести є значно більше ніж та
кількість варіантів які ми підготували
ми врахували досвід минулого року і вже
станом на сьогодні ми оперуємо приблизно
розумінням скільки дітей для до нас
прийде скільки Нам необхідно провести
змін в основній сесії тестування - це
буде дійсно в один день дві зміни до
обіду по обіді для кожної зміни буде
підготовлено унікальний набір предметних
тестів які будуть не будуть
повторюватися це раз і будуть охоплювати
програму ЗНО тобто на сьогоднішній день
наприклад для обов'язкових предметів
українська мова і математика український
центр готує щонайменше 23 варіанти
унікальних предметних тестів аби Ну
скажімо так не повторити в якійсь мірі
гіркий досвід що український центр
використовував для забезпечення вступної
кампанії
завдання які повторювалися в деяких
варіантах
попередніх днів
і уточнення буде поріг так мінімальний
бал і то Розшифруйте будь ласка
в традиційному класичному розумінні Коли
український центр встановлює його з
опертям на експертну фахову думку потім
велика комісія визначала вже
безпосередній пороговий бал Як ви
пам'ятаєте щороку він міг різнитися на
1-2 бали в бік або з пониження або
підвищення пороговий бал з плавлений
склав в класичному розумінні не буде
застосовано в ммт він вже буде наперед
визначено умовно кажучи що
учасник отримувати результат за шкалою
100 200 балів буде лише в тому випадку
якщо він набере щонайменше Вірніше не
менше 10% від максимальної кількості
тестових балів ну умовно кажучи якщо з
української мови максимальний тестовий
бал 45 то порох буде встановлено п'ять
тобто якщо дитина набирає 5 тесто балів
це і буде означати що скальований бал у
неї буде дорівнювати 100 шість наступний
крок відповідні таблиці переведення
зараз моделюємо в українському центрі їх
найближчим часом буде передано на
розгляд Міністерства Я думаю елегійович
членами робочої групи яка опрацьовує
порядок прийому їх опрацюють можливо
висловлять свої зауваження пропозиції і
ми вже їх фіналізуємо для того щоб це
також було на передвідому тобто
пороговий бал буде наперед зрозумілий і
визначений і тому абітурієнту не
потрібно буде нервово чекати допоки
комісія збереться визначить пороговий
бал потім український центр здійснить
е-е шкалювання і визначити результати
наперед дитина виходячи за межі
тимчасових екзаменаційного центру буде
знати свій тестовий бал повернувшись
додому зайшовши на сайт або українського
центру або Міністерства освіти і науки
зазирнувши в порядок прийому відповідний
додаток до цього порядку зможе одразу
зрозуміти який шкальований бал вона ма
відповідно до того тестового балу який
їй вже відомий після того як вона
пройшла nmt в пункті проведення
національного тесту Дякую чи є ще
запитання якщо запитання більше немає на
цьому ми завершуємо наш брифінг дякую
[музика]